Bruce Campbell I'm running for president
and I'm in Ashford's Eagle dead
I'm Lucy Lawless Ruby for president
studying studying I'm Lucy Lawless Ruby
for VP we're going to give you our
professional assessment of some horror
movie scenes I'm not getting it well you
know what up in space you gotta watch
the croissants they go bad real quick
for the butter oh it's just a little
mold stuff done over your head isn't
this cute it's like a little puppet
you're here your Facebook hey how are
you at the time that was one of the most
disturbing shocking sequences in motion
picture history wouldn't be great to
have been in that scene that would be
all time yeah all one of the all-time
great creepy freak out scenes yeah
that'd be good oh it's a guy in the mask
I love the other guy who played the guy
in the mask more than that guy in the
mask you know what I would say to him
show a little more expression yeah we
need a little more expression I was a
little flat inside that mask that guy's
acted up a storm right please hold look
up he's holding up that guy's more like
this is that right it's the guy it's
gone it's a guy in the mask let's put a
hockey mask on it and it'll be
completely different than the other
movies yeah not it's not a lot of
originality there we froze your little
brain oh man
that's twisted you freeze her face then
you smash your face that's cryogenics
taken to a whole new level
nice now this is a classic motion
picture this is ground rice this is what
classic motion pictures are all about
will you find out that the guy had more
blood than a rhinoceros Michelin 20 has
that girl should not have worn the socks
even when I was a kid I knew that was
not safe that was dirty it's like she
should die because she's wearing that
socks
uh is this Hellraiser oh you know what
that was good come on that was good in
there look at that wow this is just not
gonna answer keep going I think Lucy
liked that one that the rip you like the
skin being sucked right off that was
very clear that day yeah person became a
meat puppet that's what they call actors
in music meat puppets respectful of our
soft sit Jenny dip
I think this Jenny did not stop yeah it
is Jenny dead pretty good death Johnny
pretty good but not good enough that's
nice yeah yeah there was enough blood in
that scene I'll say that everyone
getting decapitated
i watch raisin wah that's so awesome
wait wait they can take them all out
that is amazing
as far as filmmaking goes that was the
best one
how did I how did I miss this ghost ship
I guess it was shite was the Rizla maybe
shy
that was the most that's Kiwi first